jeff snyder here for collider and i'm
sitting down with the team behind seven
days we're here with director roshan
sethi co-writer karen sony and his
co-star geraldine biswanathan
thank you guys for coming nice job
you guys are so sweet so uh russian
let's let's start with you for the folks
at home who haven't seen a trailer yet
uh why don't you explain what this film
is about in your own words
yeah i always find that tough because
i'm so spoiler reversed but basically
uh two two a couple is set up on an
arranged marriage date
by their old-fashioned indian parents
and they become trapped together by the
circumstances of quarantine
and sort of discover things about each
other that they didn't know before
it's a romantic comedy and and so karen
can you describe like the genesis of
this project
did you guys get stuck together during
uh quarantine and everything was this
a script that you wrote quickly at the
start of the pandemic or how did it all
sort of shake out
yeah well actually russian are in our
relationship and we were talking about
how in the middle of this time last year
how we were creatively feeling so
sort of depressed and just felt like
like june of last year like i didn't
know when the industry would open back
up which feels kind of
not that far away now but um so we were
just uh russian sort of had the idea of
being like what if we just like wrote
our own thing and just put in some of
our own money and just made
something so we didn't feel creatively
sort of just adrift
and so we very quickly sort of came up
with this idea and wrote this
in five days this script and a fever
dream because we had nothing else to do
and then sort of sent it out to a few
line producers that we knew
just to get an idea of like what would
this cost and then just as a hail mary
we send it to the duplast brothers to be
like they'll never read it but like i
had worked with them a bunch but i was
like
let me just send it out and then yeah
within a week or so they read it and
they were like we want to make this
how soon can you make it and so then
before we knew it we were like
rushing into making the movie which was
amazing um
and it's pretty much sustained us during
this whole period creatively because
we've constantly been
you know working on the post-production
and all that stuff so it's been a huge
gift to get to work on this
well i think it's really cool that you
guys saw an opportunity
you know in the stands a lot of people
got discouraged but you guys took
advantage of it
um so geraldine what did you see in this
character that made you want to take the
plunge with these guys and is it more
fun
playing a character who has a secret of
some kind um
yeah i feel like uh the boys sent me
the script and i just like fell i just
like
got all the warm fuzzy feelings and
thought it just like
worked and was beautiful and i would
do anything to um hang out with these
two beautiful
men um so i was like
sign me up i'm in and yeah i think
that's always
that duality is always really fun and
interesting to like
to play with um rather than just being
like super
upfront and honest which is more similar
to like what i am so it was cool to
to play someone who's holding cards a
little closer to the chest
um rashan and karen i'm
curious like how many couples do you
know who were wed via arranged marriages
and
and do you feel like those couples are
are more or less happier than couples
who i don't know
dated for years and did things a more
traditional way
yeah i feel like we know quite a few
mainly our relatives but including my
parents who met
seven days before they were married wow
just like the movie
in general i would say that i think
arranged marriages are as successful as
love marriages statistically speaking
since love americans are so
generally unsuccessful
in america so uh i think it's a it's a
very interesting
and valid way to meet your soulmate yeah
what's interesting about it is
this idea with love which can be so
fickle sometimes like it can sort of go
away
if you are in love with someone when
like life comes at you sometimes in
practical ways and what's interesting
about arranged marriages is you work out
all the practical stuff before like do
your families get along
are you in the same sort of like career
and like that sort of stuff and the same
culture
and so then it's just about like
connecting with the person versus
connecting first and then figuring life
out around that connection
um well i i loved like the the
testimonials that you that you you know
open and close the film with it it kind
of gave it a very hair
uh when harry met sally vibe can you
talk about that that structural decision
and how you found those couples and
whether you know were they eager to
participate or did they take some
convincing yeah originally it was
actually
scripted interviews with actors who were
playing
couples and they were going to be
interspersed throughout the movie in a
way we would figure out in editing
then we decided to just interview our
relatives because you can't make any of
them up
and then uh we had this idea of
um of the sort of book end which i won't
spoil um
yeah but we we just interviewed them
over zoom as we were preparing to make
the actual movie
it was very emotional for us to
interview them we did like about 20
minute interviews and there was your
family in my family and then some
we wanted to find some younger people
not just people that met in india or
around there
so my mom connected me to like some
doctors yeah i'm not in their
30s in america and we're completely
american born and
found this the best way to connect to
someone and each time by the end i
remember you asked the question like
what does your
partner mean to you or something like
that and people would get very emotional
yeah and we would get emotional
sometimes we'd be like
we were always like surprised by like
how the connection was
so much deeper than we thought yeah it
was yeah it was really interesting
because it's such a contrast too i don't
think there's anyone out there who's
dating who's like happy
i mean just it's easy so it's like
and then these people describing these
very simple emotional stories mary we
met each other it seemed good enough
and we've made a life together and it
was very striking
because that is uh like i said a
completely valid way
to build a family of course i mean do
you think that the younger generation of
indian americans feels pressured to
participate in an arranged marriage you
think that they're
rebelling a bit against that tradition
they're more introduced than arranged
so they're now their parents they meet
each other and then they make a decision
over a more prolonged period of time
i don't think anyone will ever do it
again the way that our
i think it also depends family to family
i think some families are more
traditional and
expect you to be with someone indian and
others don't and
oftentimes if you want to be with some
someone indian america such a big place
and
these websites and ways to connect are
often quite easy to meet
people you know across the united states
so it sort of serves as like a
halfway point between that um geraldine
you you and karen have uh great
chemistry
in this uh movie and i know you worked
together previously on miracle workers
do you feel like having that shorthand
having done a tv show together sort of
helped you on this set
100 um it
we just we just fell right into it like
it was just so easy and yeah we've done
three
i guess we'd only done yeah two seasons
of the show together by that point and
yeah there was a total shorthand and i
think we really like
understand each other as performers and
like what our strengths are
and um and we're friends so it's like
easy to improvise together and and all
that so that was that was the easy part
yeah and the geraldine started like this
was not an easy shoot
we shot a lot of pages a day it was the
environmental conditions were very hot
it was a heat wave it was like 110
degrees every day and
and it was not easy or glamorous in any
way and she really sort of came in and
just
was so prepared and just killed it and
it just made all of it so easy because
for me and russian it was like we were
doing
a lot of these jobs for the first time
like in terms of we had never had a
movie made or
any of that so it was so nice to know
that she was there to just
when we needed her to shine she would
shine and yeah
and it was it was very punishing
honestly for both of them
to know that many pages memorize that
many lines i mean i was wearing gym
clothes for the entire trip
but they they're wearing these costumes
geraldine is doing her own makeup i mean
the whole thing was very like
difficult but um and and
russia i want to ask you about the
timing of this movie because um
i mean you're an actual doctor right
like why why was this summer in the
midst of everything that the right time
go off and make your future debut well i
had finished residency and i'd always
juggled screenwriting and residency for
so long for five years to be exact and i
had never had my own uninterrupted time
to be creative
and i wasn't starting my attending job
which i've now begun
until november so i had these these
months
to make something to do something so
that was why
why now i only work for 12 weeks of the
year i have a great
deal um where i can be creative in the
times that i'm not in the hospital
that is a good deal and since you are a
doctor i actually have this thing on my
shoulder
yeah biopsy look at those extremes
biopsy
medical advice about i would say 99 of
things
so specialized but uh yeah hit me up
after this interview
and i'll connect you to some people
sounds good karen i wanted to ask about
um you know
there's been a lot of talk about uh
deadpool 3 and whatnot have you heard
anything about the return of
dopinder potentially no i haven't heard
anything i just have like
i originally signed for four movies so i
saw a two movie contract that's in an
email somewhere that exists
uh but that's all i really know yeah i
haven't really heard um
anything i think prior before it sold to
disney like
at fox i know there was a lot of plans
and they would actually be more
communicative then but now once that the
disney thing happened it's very uh
it's all a mystery to what is happening
we get to make more it would be so fun
to see that character
in that expanded world but also to see
kevin feige's
sort of take on what to do with it
because he's obviously
such a huge x-men fan and he's getting
to play with those characters in our
world now so
hope we get to see something with it
sure no i know a lot of the folks at
collider are stoked for that
sequel good movie coming up called the
rumble what can you tell us about that
movie
oh um it's a little cutie
it's uh it's
um set in the world of monster wrestling
well wrestling but it's monsters i
should be clear um
but that's coming out in i think
february next year
in theaters so paramount pictures which
is russian's favorite studio favorite
studio he owns multiplayer
t-shirts i got some shirts from their
gift shop
uh and and rasha what can you tell me
about your um
the abortion drama that you have coming
up called jane with with elizabeth banks
what is switching subject huh i uh so
yeah that really owes a lot of credit to
um the co-writer on it haley shore whose
uh mother's friend uh knew was a part of
this movement the jain movement in the
late 60s
and we wrote the script many years ago
actually it was on the blacklist in 2017
and then
it finally got made uh just this last
month
um i wasn't involved to be honest with
the production at all
but but yeah it that has been a mammoth
effort getting that movie made we're so
grateful to elizabeth and sigourney for
finally signing up to do it
have you started thinking about what
your next feature might be
yeah we toss around ideas all the time
nothing concrete but
um yeah it all depends on how much money
someone will give us
to make it come true we're like here's
if we get more money what we would make
and if we get
no money what we will eventually just do
a kind of before after sunset version of
seven days where these two are getting
divorced in the next movie
um
it's called 14 days oh gosh
can we go into weeks
that could be really interesting
especially where you leave it and i
won't spoil anything
uh we have to let audiences find this
one at the tribeca film festival this
week
well thank you to the team behind seven
days for joining us
look forward soon in theaters geraldine
karen
roshan thank you so much